votre maison comme une belle petite maison Jack
êtes-vous autorisé à parler en cours de route
Je pensais qu'il pourrait y avoir des règles laissez-moi le
dire de cette façon si vous faites tout
le chemin sans dire un mot mais vous
êtes clairement joyeux ne le faites pas  crois que
tu vas me dire quelque chose je suis
troisième avant
[Musique]
donc j'étais peut-être une erreur quelle était
mon erreur en montant dans cette voiture avec toi
tu pourrais aussi bien être un tueur en série
désolé mais tu ressembles un peu à un
[Musique]
Je suis définitivement
certaines personnes affirment que les atrocités que nous
commettons dans notre fiction sont ces
désirs intérieurs que nous ne pouvons pas commettre dans notre
civilisation contrôlée, donc ils
s'expriment plutôt à travers notre art Je
ne suis pas d'accord
Je crois au paradis  et l'enfer ne font
qu'un l'âme appartient au paradis et le
corps à l'enfer
oeuvres sublimes cachées dans le  les
coins les plus sombres pour que Dieu seul puisse voir la même
chose pour le meurtre
[Musique]
vous